les grandes écoles qui fait de chaque
gars d'être monsieur mitterrand nombre
de réglages ce qu'il convient aux
déclarations et plus démagogique une
suppression jeu en tout cas cela passe
peut-être par une augmentation des
diplômés des grandes écoles
patrick club d'aller décrocher le bac
c'est un bac à dominante mathématiques
31 centrale emile huchet pendant deux
années dans des tasses préparatoire
extrêmement sélectif est tout ça mais
ces élections par la matière mais auprès
de 1005 raciale les éléments
j'étais perdue contre sept hommes
appartiennent à des catégories
supérieures les écoles de commerce
souvent des gens pour apaiser parce que
c'est cher et on éprouve à ces critiques
d'oublier pour laquelle la france mes
parents ils entreprennent largement le
pam a recruté un papa malade et voter
certaines activités
nous voulions voir les comptes et pas la
plus grand nombre c'est le but du
président de la république
une hécatombe reçus par le directeur de
l'école centrale détruire le projet de
l'école centrale qui aujourd'hui donne
satisfaction d'ensemble aux employeurs
pour multiplier par un homme que je ne
peux pas déterminé le manque de diplôme
ou un profil différent ça ne me paraît
pas être le souhaitera il faut l'horizon
2000 la france a besoin de plus de 300
nouveaux ingénieurs difficulté ce que
l'archer le recrutement tout en gardant
un niveau de qualification
internationalement reconnu comme étant
l'un des meilleurs